What Are Equivalent Sets to Understand Consider These Four Random Sets
Cardinal
Number The cardinal number of a set is the number
of elements present in that set to know which
of those sets are equivalent let's find
the cardinal numbers of each of the sets
the set a has three elements so n of a is the
set b has  Four elements which tells us that
n of b is four and similarly n of
c is 4 and n of d is three these are the
cardinal numbers of each of the sets we can see that these two
cardinal numbers are
equal so we can say that  Set a is
equivalent to set d and since the cardinal
numbers of these two sets are equal we can
say that set b is equivalent to set c
Remember they are equivalent not equal that brings us to the
question when are they
equal we will see that in  The Next Video
For Now Just Remember That If The Number Of
Elements In Two Sets Are Equal They Are Called
Equivalent
[Music]
Sets